breaking news in a shocking new report
surrounding john kerry
and the world's leading state sponsor of
terrorism
that would be the muellers and that
would be iran according to leaked audio
obtained by the new york times
iran's top diplomat guy by the name of
muhammad zarif
claims that john kerry compromised one
of
our top allies and us in the process
by divulging potentially top secret
highly sensitive information quote
former secretary of state john kerry
informed him
that israel had attacked iranian
interest in syria
at least 200 times to his astonishment
mr zarif said
to his astonishment did john kerry
reveal
israeli covert actions to
israel and the us's single biggest enemy
the number one state sponsor of
terrorism worldwide
well that would mean all plausible
deniability
for covert operations would be dead gone
and buried
covert operatives and assets on the
ground risking their lives
they would be in imminent danger if they
haven't already been murdered
something we likely wouldn't know and of
course john kerry
is saying that this never happened but
the new york times is standing by
the accuracy of their reporting keep in
mind kerry reportedly
had been in contact with iranian
officials ever since leaving the obama
administration
see that's only a problem if you're a
conservative or a republican
then it's a violation of the 1799 logan
act
and by the way if you go back in the
trump administration
kerry still in communication with iran
really what if what if what if the trump
supporters were doing that now
president trump accused him rightly so
of undermining our foreign policy that's
our national security
and after all it appeared that kerry was
trying to preserve his crowning
achievement
the now defunct the dumbest deal in the
history of mankind
the iranian nuclear deal that joe biden
wants to leap back into
you know the one that gave 150 billion
dollars in cash and other currency
to the leading state sponsor terrorism
and in exchange
we got nothing u.s led checks on nuclear
sites
none anywhere anytime inspections
none any verifiable guarantees none
even our own inspectors none just tens
of billions of dollars that iran
immediately was using
to fund further terror attacks all over
the region and world
remember the architect of this idiotic
deal has been trying to appease
iran for now over a decade all while
vilifying
our top ally in the middle east israel
at every turn
and as one article in the new york post
entitled john kerry
is skirting the line of treason with
iran
summed it up the rather curious defining
feature of the democratic party foreign
policy going back at least four decades
is that our friends must be bullied our
enemies must be appeased
not shocking given kerry's testimony you
might recall when he ran for president
when this tape came up it was him in the
1970s
accusing his fellow soldiers in vietnam
of being oh murderers rapists randomly
shooting civilians
raising villages in a fashion on
rem reminiscent of
in his words genjus khan take a listen
they had personally raped cut off ears
cut off heads taped wires from portable
telephones to human genitals and turned
up the power
cut off limbs blown up bodies
randomly shot at civilians raised
villages in the fashion reminiscent of
genji's khan
clearly john kerry's not changed at all
and now multiple members of congress are
calling on kerry to resign or be
investigated
that's the least of it senator sullivan
from alaska
among many others even mitt romney found
a little bit of courage somewhere
the old mitt romney popped out for a
second to criticize the democrat
and called for full transparency
whatever that means
but former secretary of state mike
pompeo he believes iran's top diplomat
including zarif
might be frequently out of the loop with
iran's ruling factions has little power
frequently lies
which mean even kerry's alleged attempts
to undermine
our closest ally might have been
fruitless take a look
but as for zarif i don't know why
anybody listens to him he has nothing to
do with iranian foreign policy he lies
all the time now regardless of zarif and
john kerry it's now clear that the
hostile regime in iran is testing this
new administration
you know the weak the frail the
cognitively struggling
joe in kamala harris last night in the
persian gulf
three iranian revolutionary guards
patrol boats
plowed through waters towards u.s naval
ships and what the navy called an
unnecessarily close
range with unknown intent after radio
loudspeaker warnings were ignored the
u.s navy was forced to fire several
warning shots
at that time the iranian vessels finally
retreated but no doubt
this will not be the last time the biden
administration is tested
the question tonight is well is joe
biden
up to the task hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else